what's up guys it's federico welcome
back to this 36th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour and so
far we've made thirty four thousand
seven hundred
and fourteen dollars i thought we we
made more than that we're at thirty
three more
more why was i thinking we gotta
congratulate you for one of the most
flawless introductions to the podcast
didn't waste a beat you just
no i said this is what you're gonna say
and you're just like all right here we
go and you just said it
how many youtubers do you guys i mean i
i
watch your main channel and i watch your
second channel but
i do this for a living i mean
everyone else every youtube person we
have on is a youtuber and they can
yeah well that just goes to show my lack
of preparation for this video
that was that was impressive yeah but i
think with your videos you don't script
them
no never there's a little bit of cutting
by the way guys thirty four thousand
seven hundred and fourteen dollars and
ninety cents
is what i mean on like my first four
years of youtube really
well i'm a much smaller channel i'm
about to hit
a hundred thousand that's at federico
talks watchers help me out
um but yeah i mean now this year it's
it's doing a lot better yeah it took a
while yeah first we have to thank this
videosponsorprivacy.com okay everyone
listen up to get some free money i'm
gonna put you on to something i've been
using a ton lately and that is
privacy.com
isn't it super annoying when you're
required to put in credit card
information to access a website do you
ever sign up for free trials and worry
that you will forget to cancel before
they charge you is it ever difficult for
you to unsubscribe
or stop paying for an online service
privacy.com lets you buy things online
using virtual cards instead of having to
use your real ones protecting your
identity and bank information on the
internet privacy is absolutely
incredible
all you have to do is link a card to
your account and then you can create 12
single use debit cards per month that
you can set specific limits to
and cancel whenever so when you're
buying anything online the seller will
not have your credit card information
this is huge in protection from fraud if
you go with the privacy premium plan you
can actually
get cash back and rewards alongside all
of the other perks that come with this
plan head to privacy.com
ich and sign up for an account new
customers will automatically get five
dollars to spend on your first purchase
go to privacy.com ich and sign up now as
always the link will be in the
description thank you privacy for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
let me introduce you because this is
really exciting for me to meet you
i've been watching your channel for
maybe two years
two and a half years now for a while uh
and i was interested in your channel
because you talked watches
and i love watches and you you sell
watches you're involved in watches and i
think they're really interesting
one because aesthetically i think they
could be very beautiful
but also for an investment they retain
their value some of them go
up a lot in value i've been trying to
convince jack to get a submariner
he's shaking his head he's saying no but
i think
we'll talk about that shortly that's my
man right there blind man for
anybody i think who's interested in
watches or who wants to get into watches
or who is
at all curious about maybe alternative
investments where you could make money
or if you have cash that's sitting in an
account
to put it in a watch this is your guy
and we're going to learn a lot today
about about investing and
buying watches and you're going to react
to
my watch collection i brought a few
watches all right so
uh no holds barred though no hold spark
now um but you know
i do appreciate you having me on because
honestly i'm not just saying this for
the show
i have actually been watching you not
quite two years but
definitely over a year um and like yeah
i'm a youtuber
but this is a whole other level for me
so um
i don't know i'm kind of honored to be
here and meet you guys thank you so much
for the opportunity you're welcome
how did you get into selling watches all
right so this story was
we're doing the brutal honesty brutal
honesty all right so
my parents were jewelers right and
jewelry designers i was not really my
thing as a kid
my older brother was actually sitting
somewhere over there got me into
he was obsessed with watchers around the
age of 18 i was about 10 11.
so he'd always like call me over to take
a look at the stuff online i never
really cared
but then i turned 18 and
i didn't really know what to do with my
life i wasn't a great student i mean i
went to college
decided it wasn't for me moved back home
and my mom was like all right we'll go
get a job
you know like go do something and i
walked down
fifth avenue with a stack of resumes
walk to the gap banana republic cartier
starbucks gucci whatever every single
sort on fifth avenue
and the manager cartier was like well
we're looking for like
a sales associate for christmas in the
watch department
do you know anything about watches well
actually
a little bit he's like all right sell me
this pen
you know no is that really no
literally he took it from a movie
there's a famous movie where that
happened yeah
wall street is it well this is a foreign
no wasn't that the uh
the the stock with the gordon gecko uh
what was that actually i don't know i
think it was remember jordan belfort had
like
yeah he did that that was wolf of wall
street but i think it was um
well this was 2009 so it was before a
wolf of wall street
wow um i know i just worked out and he
gave me the job 12 bucks an hour
and by the sixth week i was the
second out of like 60 sales people in
the whole fifth avenue store
why um just because you knew about
watches well no it had nothing to do
with
knowing about watchers because they
didn't know anything about watchers i
then dedicated my life to spending like
the 12 hours of not the 12 non-working
hours a day i had
to reading timezone.com like that's when
it started
but no it's it's literally just about
being
to my own horn but charming and
conversation you are pretty charming
making people feel comfortable there's
nothing worse than walking into one of
these stuffy boutiques
yeah and and it being so rigid i mean
you have to have a little decorum but
it's all about connecting with the
person yeah connect with the person
they'll buy anything
be a good real estate agent you would be
you're a very good conversationalist as
soon as you walked in the room you
started talking
very easy very easy to talk to you yeah
i think you
you make the air comfortable well you
guys are making me blush
if i could blush very charming yeah
but no because honestly if you go in any
of these boutiques today
most of the sales people are in their
50s you know they're tired they're over
it
buy something and get out i was not even
20 years old like i really wanted to
make an impression and
you know it worked yeah and then what
happened after that so how much were you
making back think we asked that
yeah it was uh 12 an hour one percent
commission
that's it um well it was a holiday
because i was a holiday associate so i
was getting paid exactly half what
everybody was
wow everybody was on i guess 25 and 2
percent
but i probably made i don't remember
honestly but
probably about i was making probably
like sixty five thousand dollars
that's pretty good it's good you know
and in that challenge
yeah um and then i went to work for
another store
uh called torno was not for me
dad particularly and then i went to work
for 1p
which free plug to 1p greatest watch
store in the world as far as i'm
concerned on 5th avenue
best trained sales staff the nicest guys
coffee
champagne they treat everybody like
royalty whether you're buying a strap
or a million dollar patek sleep they
taught me everything i know so if my old
boss is watching me thank you
um and then yeah it was basically all
retail
and then and then i moved into corporate
what do you mean moved into corporate so
i was a retail sales associate
and then i just didn't want to be behind
the counter you know for
my whole life which sounds dramatic
cause it was only about five years
back then um and then i applied for a
job at the richmond group which is a
company that owns
a ton of watch brands vacheron
constantine cartier
panerai all those and there was a brand
called piaget they were looking for
in a wholesale sales manager which
basically my job was
to sell the store their watches so
instead of the customer being my
my customer the stores were my customer
so i got that job
and i was the youngest sales rep in the
u.s at the time
um traveled the us trying to open
doors open jewelers to sell piaget i was
going extremely well
i don't know if you know this but about
80 of those sales back then were
actually chinese tourism
um it was a great way to launder money
uh
so what would they do they spring cash
buy a watch and then take the watch back
with them and yeah give it to like their
local
party official as a gift or something
then the government changed
left xi jinping is the new president uh
crackdown and watch sales went down the
toilet
quicker than the great depression um
i knew the writing was on the wall so i
decided to
leave before in fact looking back at
piaget
nobody i worked with worked there
anymore i was the first one to leave i
decided
to leave on my own terms but good
decision in hindsight because
you know no one's there and then i was
unemployed i was bored
i decided to start talking about
watchers on youtube
talking about watchers talking about
watchers a couple years
no real money making coming out of it
but it was fine
but people would ask me hey federico
would you buy this or where can i buy
this
and i decided to you know how do i
monetize this
so you know a long story short a few
more steps but i started delraywatch.com
which is my website and i started it on
an investment with a partner
you know my partner john was also on
youtube we started with four thousand
dollars
all right that was our investment and
i'm not going to tell you exactly what
the revenue is but it's it's
multi multi multi millions of dollars
per year that was a good four thousand
dollar investment
um no if you why did you have a partner
in the beginning
um because i'm good at watches
okay i love watches of what i do i don't
do technology
i don't do websites i don't do credit
card processing
i don't do legal and john who was a cta
you know was a cto consultant for a big
watch company
at the time you know was a good friend
of mine and you know i told him my idea
and he's like
let's let's do it you know we literally
we were having
tacos and tequila and i'm like you know
i had this idea we should do it
and he's like absolutely i'm on board
and three weeks later it started
and um i mean listen first year was
tough
but and it still is we're a small
company you know we're not
you know like uh we're not crowning
caliber or or rolex or anything but
yeah it started with four thousand
dollars that's all it took and how long
ago was that
just under four years ago how many
employees do you have now
full time we have well there's me and
john
jacob who is our office assistant
jonathan hochman our director of
operations carlos ramos our photographer
hanzo watchmaker
and then so i don't whatever that is
plus an extra watchmaker
for repairs on the side because we have
a lot of
demand and then a part-time account and
the part-time lawyer so how does your
business work do you
try to find good deals on watches you
buy them and then you sell them
so yes in a nutshell you kind of got it
but there's a couple twists
that i feel that we do that nobody else
does that's right first of all we're
watch collectors first
me and john are watch lovers all right
every watch dealer sells rolex
patek philippe and audemars piguet
that's boring to me because that's
everybody does that don't get me wrong
there's some pateks i love
some aps i love but there's so much more
out there so we started by buying the
stuff that not a lot of people
knew about like my favorite brand h
moser i'm pretty convinced i saw more
hmoser than most hmos or stores in the
us
at the moment i don't think i've heard
of that brand um well there's one that
i'm gonna show you that i brought in
um you know gerard perego zenith
breitling corvoe sabrino's
just the stuff that's not in the big
three and nobody else was selling it so
when we started selling it if people
wanted it we weren't in a few places you
could buy it
because every watch dealer was scared to
invest in that kind of stock
because oh who's going to buy you know
it's scary they'd rather buy
a rolex and flip it and make a couple
hundred dollars
whereas to me you know i found that
boring so i started stocking the stuff i
like
and then obviously i started promoting
it on my youtube channel
and my youtube channel is all watch
geeks so they loved the stuff i was
stalking
because they were also bored of the same
old same old
so yeah that's pretty much why can't you
just go to west time
and say hey i want to buy this h moser
what is it moses moser why can't you
just go to west time and say that and
then they just go and source it and sell
it to you for
well first you have to be an authorized
dealer um so i don't know if west time
is but they very well may be but
that's where the investment part of
watches comes in i'm not going to sit
here
and tell you that watchers are a good
investment watches are not necessarily a
good investment
but they're a fantastic hobby where you
can
very easily not lose money
it's a great way to have a ton of fun
park some money and if you do it right
you can make money or not necessarily
lose money there's very few
expensive hobbies that one can say about
that
and moser if you buy a moser at west
time
and you go sell it in three years
because you're tired of it
thirty five thousand dollar watch is
worth eight grand
you go to del rey watch and you buy
pre-owned not to plug my own business
again it's nine thousand dollars
yeah so when you go to sell it back to
me it's eight thousand dollars
or maybe the market went up and you get
your 9 000 back or you make or maybe
i'll give you 10 000 depends when you
sell it
but let somebody else take the
depreciation you know
the pre-owned watch in good condition
from a well-known dealer
is just as good as one that's brand new
well really quickly guys we have a word
from our sponsor audible audible is the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment audiobooks and they
recently added podcasts i'm someone who
values constantly learning new things
and audible is an amazing platform that
offers over 500
000 audio titles audible offers spoken
word entertainment ranging from
celebrity memoirs and motivational
speeches to original content from
celebrity creators and thousands of
binge-worthy podcasts
i'm way too busy right now to divert all
of my attention to a book and read
so instead i just put on audible when
i'm doing my daily runs or in my car
driving i am currently listening to
misbehaving which is a book by richard
thaler on behavioral economics and its
effect on us
i know i definitely would not have
enough time to read this book if it
weren't for audible and guess what guys
you're in luck because right now you can
get in on the president's day event
you are getting in on one of the best
offers of the year it's only 9.95 a
month for your first six months
when i signed up for audible about eight
months ago i was paying way more than
this
so if you want to check that out visit
audible.com iced coffee or text iced
coffee to 500
500. it's as easy as that just text iced
coffee to 500
500 also if you want more information as
always check the description and with
that said
back to the podcast now you mentioned
for jack because i've been telling
jacket a submariner
get it i i think that would be a good
watch for jack to get
that would only go up in value you said
that's a double-edged sword
why well i think on a submariner it's a
safe investment
um it's a great first watch if you can
afford it
uh jack can afford it first off i cannot
afford it
second off i i i agree with you i don't
think that you can justify it as an
investment and that would be the only
reason why i would get a want i'm gonna
disagree with you here i think a
submariner historically speaking
has only gone up in value but it's going
to be one of those things where
even if we're best friends in the world
i can't help you with because a
pre-owned submariner sells
more than a than a new one because
they're sold out everywhere
so is it listen if you have the money to
responsibly afford it
you're not you know you're not going to
lose at least in the market
at least historically based on the past
10 years of data
you can't how much do they cost like
what's that
it's you're probably gonna say seven
seventy five hundred right now are we
talking like the new ceramic version no
what would you advise i'd say i'd say
going on like chrono 24
going on ebay getting like a a 15 year
old submariner so if you go with the
aluminum version which i like
um you know it's made significantly
worse
but it's more charming you know like 7
500 maybe 8 grand
if you go with the new aluminum version
you're probably talking like
10 10 and a half why so much why have
they gone up so much in value
all of them have you know um i'm
not a huge fan of rolex i personally
find them boring even though i do own
one i own two
actually why because they're a marketing
machine
i mean it's a status symbol it's the it
thing to have
uh it's a great watch nothing against
the watch but whenever you walk into a
rolex boutique
and they laugh at you you know like oh
you have the submariner and you should
throw their head back and laugh
and call security you know what i mean
that's the reason why
because they're sold out everywhere it's
one of those things where it is
it is what it is um i mean the
submariner is worn by james bond you
know or before omega
there was the submariner before the
submariner there was the explorer when
fleming wrote the books
so it represents this like cool
sophisticated machismo or you buy a sub
you kind of feel like james bond
it's it it's also one of the few sports
watches you can wear to the office
in a suit and it looks great or you
could
you know wear like with t-shirt like
graham's wearing now and it looks great
it's something you can keep for the
entire your entire life
and hand it down and it's it's a great
great watch
but as a watch collector and dealer um
you know you get over it a little bit
because it's
everywhere you know for jack it's
perfect
honestly it's a great way you won't lose
money
it's a great way to start if you never
want another watch for the rest of your
life
you're set forever or it could start a
deep and ugly addiction where you spend
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
online
hundreds of thousands of dollars i wish
i could have hundreds of thousands of
dollars to spend
well you'll get there eventually see
yeah jack i do think you should be
getting a submariner
are we not going to be talking about the
the move oh let's talk about the movie
yeah i know it looks like we teleported
everyone we we saw the uh the footage
and it looks like
very harsh lighting so we just had to
move and this is actually a better
setting i think actually
so if you guys like this more we could
do our future podcast like this yeah
i like it like this because you see the
smash like button which is a good
reminder
to smash like button for the youtube
algorithm yeah but
for the submariner so first off just do
it
but just do it but i don't think i
should do it
7 500 but also i feel like i would be i
would be embarrassed to wear it
it's like too narrow it's too nice it's
too nice
i think really respect that train of
thought okay i do because it means
you're a humble guy but everybody
deserves to treat themselves
this would be a watch that you would buy
that you'd be so proud of
that you could pass down to your
children to your gran this is this is
that i like that aspect but this is an
heirloom piece
that you're going to buy once as a sim
to me that's a symbol of hard work
saving and dedication to get a watch
like that and that's going to be a
constant reminder of like
look what i was able to accomplish and
what i purchased and that's a sign of
hard work that's what i see it as
that and it's still safe i mean it's
safe if you really
don't feel comfortable with it
you can always give me a call i just
don't know like what occasion i would
wear it for
like do you wear it out you won't wear
it all the time yeah that's a watch well
no
and you're only in your house or like
you know like if you're going to like i
don't know like
like a party with fancy investor people
i feel like i would wear it no
reasonably there i think the city the
submariner is a watch
that you could wear while you're putting
together ikea furniture
when you're playing football with your
buds while you're at the gym
while you're digging in the dirt when
you're in the shower it's one of those
watches that
that i think you could keep on your
wrist 24 7
and it will it it's meant to take a
beating that once and it looks
better as it patinas with age
i'll tell you what when i get an
investment property
i think that that would be a good way to
how about this
yeah i would settle for you getting it
on like uh like either a birthday
uh or on a milestone like when the
podcast it's a hundred thousand
subscribers we're just picking that
because it's within the next five days
yeah but but that would be like when the
podcast is a hundred thousand
it's probably already hit a hundred
thousand by this week so by next week
you get the watch all right i think on a
milestone
that's when you do that i think graham's
right because it makes it even
more special when you finally acquire
this piece
to attach a watch with a memory is
something men have been doing it
men have been doing for generations and
you know there's something beautiful
about that you know why not being a
birthday or or
when you get your investment property or
whatever it may be
i think a milestone if you could pick a
significant milestone that you could
remember for the rest of your life
whether it be a specific birthday
or buying a rental property how about
this the day i retire
no no but then the watch is going to be
like 40 years
okay all right so i like the uh the
investment property because i
i it's so hard for me to get a watch
just i feel like i'm
i understand where you're coming from
like it holds value but i feel like i'm
still it's like
i can't view it as an investment so i
need to do something you have more cash
sitting in a bank account probably just
losing money and interest
here's the thing you you don't need an
emergency fund unless they keep the
emergency fund in the watch
really yeah you can you know why don't
you have like 50 watches then i'll make
you a deal what
i and this is it's on video okay
if you need the cash i will buy the
watch for you at whatever it's worth or
the same price you paid
that's a deal i'll make that same deal
if i need the cash
my only condition i'm serious my only
condition is that
i would have proven the price you pay
just so you're not paying like 15k for a
submariner be like
graham you gotta pay if you get a good
used
submariner i will buy it at the same
price that you paid for it
if you need the money if i need it yes
what if i want it
you're not going to sell it i i know
once you get it you're not going to sell
it you're not going to say why would you
do that the only reason you get rid of
that watch is if you're like
graham the stock market just collapsed
my investments are worth
nothing the algorithm just shadow banned
all of us
i'm like i i need the cash right now
what if i need like an advance
for um for like if i want to make a down
payment
and i would give you an advance i would
i would i'll pay you ahead of time for
for the money that you're earning you're
always a month ahead anyway i know
i'll pay you that very generous yeah i
know he's a good he's a good boss yeah
but i'll do that because that's how
confident i am because
one i know that the rolex market is not
going to collapse
whatever price you pay is going to be a
fair part you're going to get a good
deal on the watch
i know i'm not going to lose any money
i've always wanted the submariner too
never done it but i would buy yours so
there's no risk
there's no risk all right i'll do it in
in that case yes
peer pressure i it's just like i don't
think you realize seven thousand dollars
is
so much money like i think of that in in
uh denominations of like
a hundred dollar bills you know how many
hundred dollar bills that is hold this
how much
wait wait let jack hold it let jack hold
it and then
that is just watching that is a shoe bag
with about four hundred thousand dollars
of watches in it
jack has the best reactions what if jack
just gets something to run
please please open it up and i i brought
a few
watches for you guys to look at watchers
that are great investments
and watchers that are god awful
investment all right how about that
let's see these we got a segway into it
i'm just going to open this up by the
way jack what milestone
would you get the rental property when
you buy a rental property you will buy
it that will happen this year federico
would you be able to help
jack get a submariner or is that
something you can do it's you
oh you don't have to no the truth is i'm
sold out of submariners at all times
but i want to of course just give me a
call
give me a call we'll figure it out i'm
just going to class
wow see look what i'm doing for you jack
you have no idea
all right i'm going to open this up all
right two hands so there are two watches
inside of here
can i just please please go nuts
this is a gerard parago perpetual
calendar chronograph
f50 no okay wait that is
don't don't let me let me let jack guess
how much
that is first and then let me see it and
then i'll come up with this
well there's something special about it
this was only ever originally sold
to owners of the original ferrari f50 if
you didn't own an f50 gerard parago
would not sell you this watch
all right well let me s let me see this
before it jacks pretty heavy
yeah solid white gold all right let me
see
that is gorgeous and we'll get some
b-roll of this yeah
so it says f50 on it
when ferrari came out with their
supercar the f50 they offered all the
original owners of the f50 the option to
buy this watch
and they engraved their name on the back
does that bring down the value to have
someone else's name
on the back usually yes but all ferrari
f50 owners
are usually somebody special and that is
engraved with
guy la liberte who is the
founder of cirque du soleil no way
so that is originally laliberte's
so i'm gonna tell you i think the
difficult part of this watch is
that uh it's hard to comp this and it's
really just
whatever is someone willing to pay for
it i would guess
this would be 60. what would you weigh
what do you say jack
see i was gonna say i was gonna say 40
but i have no like you're asking me i
have no idea this could be a watch that
i think on the low end would be
25 in the low end maybe 120 at the high
end
so original retail i don't remember but
it was original full retail price was
about
five to guess about 80 000 but gerard
pergo is not a brand that holds value
well
so i bought this at hong kong in auction
physically at auction um i paid ten
thousand
um but i can tell you being that it's an
f50 so they made very few
the connection with somebody famous
gaila liberte and then it's perpetual
calendar chronograph
i bought this specifically because it's
i think it's worth
two to three times what i paid for it so
down the line right it's about 30. i'm
already selling it at del rey watch i
think it's a touch under 20.
yeah because i'm a business i can't keep
everything up right
i have to pay the rent but if you put in
the fact that it's rare
the functionality the original retail
price i do think
it will eventually be worth 30 to 40
again yeah
um it's grossly undervalued why did why
did this take such a hit
um gerard perego was just a grossly
mismanaged company
fantastic watchmaker um
fantastically horrible business people
they don't know how to market
um you know even today they make some of
the best watchers on earth
heavily discounted um you know gerard
perego is not
a good investment if you pay full retail
i'm looking straight into the camera as
i say that
i got a question um this may sound
really stupid
please but what makes a watch like good
because in my opinion i mean i know
nothing about watches right like
just so you have an understanding where
i'm coming from what makes this watch
so much better than like a rolex so
there's
three things in my opinion that make a
watch good
the first one is just mechanics right
engineering and mechanics
which rolex's makes fantastic mechanics
and jordan parago does great mechanics
as well
second which this is well above a rolex
is
finishing how much time and manual
effort
went into making that watch if you open
up the movement of this watch it's all
hand engraved
hand finished under a microscope by a
master watchmaker
whereas rolex fantastic watch it's more
of a production line watch
you know it's it's it's made in bulk and
then
third is something called complications
which in watches
refers to functions so what functions
does this have
it is a chronograph which is a stopwatch
and then on top of that
it's a perpetual calendar which is a
calendar
that equates for the changes in month so
30 31
and 28 days and for leap year which
this is not digital this is all done
with springs
and gears what about accuracy
wouldn't that be like the most important
thing so yes
it was back in the day but nowadays
where iphones are so accurate
two dollar timex watches with quartz
movements are more accurate than this
the beauty in this is it doesn't have a
microchip it doesn't have
right it's it's all powered it's keeping
something so accurate
all through the power of springs levers
and ears
which are hand assembled i mean that is
you know how hard that is it's it's art
it's not
art yes it's art what got me into it was
watching a patek philippe
be built there's a youtube video on it
love that video yeah
the craftsmanship all right i gotta
check that out it makes you want that
watch like for me i i want to patek on
my 50th birthday
purposely i want to wait until i'm 50
because i feel like that's a milestone
where you could get a potato how much
does those cost
uh i would say probably the one maybe
about 100 grand
it depends which one you want but i mean
this is there are five dollar watches
which
spank this all over the place in terms
of accuracy
it's not about accuracy anymore it's
it's craftsmanship
and appreciating the watch yeah as an
art piece
i get it this is it is a very good
looking
so this is a great example of a watch
that was an awful investment
but that i think is poised to make
a very big comeback okay especially for
the price that it's
now being offered at let's see what else
is in here so
obviously what affects the price is the
demand but
what affects the demand is it those
three components that you gave
um no no no demand is much more
marketing people love to have what other
people have
which is why rolex is king you know
rolex is a great watch but
it's an icon what makes an icon the fact
that i belong
on it um you know there's other small
brands like this next one you're going
to pull out
they make less than 2 000 watches a year
they have no idea nobody knows what this
brand is
it's hmoser but it's my favorite brand
because i'm a watch nerd
and i just love everything that they
stand for
but at the same time it also means it's
not a particularly good investment at
the moment
but it is something that i think in the
future once their story
is a little bit more widespread should
pick
what i think with rolex right now is
that i remember
back when i was uh i don't know a kid
you'd watch like the
the golf tournaments and you'd see it
all with the rolex crown
yeah but now i think you see so many
youtubers
that are all buying rolexes yeah and now
it's the cool watch
i think it went from being like this
grandpa watch that like oh you have a
rolex or grandpa might have owned a
rolex in the day
now it's cool now it's like all the kids
when they make money
the first thing they do is they buy a
rolex and every other youtube video is
like
buying a rolex i bought a rolex
surprising my sister with the rolex
fantastic views yes it's it's you know
what it's actually become
the lamborghini of watches yeah it's the
gallardo
yeah oh yeah 100 it gets it's just
they don't care what rolex it is it's a
rolex
i mean i put rolex in the title i got
forty percent more views without even
it's the lamb yeah let's see what else
what else do we got
see that moser this one is not for sale
it is a personal watch of mine so this
is an h
moser perpetual moon phase with a
aventurine dial
what is aventurine it is a hard gemstone
dial that
naturally sparkles in the light moser
only made 50 watches of these
in their history and
when i saw it i had to have it wait so
what's the uh what's the dial at the
bottom that's the moon phase
that is a moon phase so you could track
where the moon
exactly and which is not a particularly
useful complication
but it is a well it's cool i call it
romantic
right it harkens back to when things
like that were useful i mean i don't
never need to know when the phases of
the moon are but if i'm gonna have
something mechanical and beautiful like
that
right it is i don't know i think it's a
nice touch and it gives the dial a
little bit a little bit of depth
it's a cool looking how do you set this
how do you do you look at the moon one
night you're like okay i'm gonna
dial it into so you can google moon
phase calendars yeah
even though i'm i'm not gonna lie to
your audience i've never once set the
moon phase yeah now
this is okay so this is cool h moses so
i'm gonna
so if you say nobody really knows about
it they make two if they make two
thousand watches a year
i'm saying they're at least probably
charging five grand
minimum no much higher much i'm gonna
say twenty
much higher 20 well i've never seen
anything like this that's what makes it
so unique
is it what's it what's this isn't white
gold no this is stainless steel
more special because fine watchers like
this
are rarely made in stainless steel why
um because gold is more noble
even though stainless steel is
technically a better metal
because it's harder it doesn't scratch
as easy
it looks newer but it doesn't have the
cachet of gold
this one this watch had a retail price
of 35 000.
what a 50 what is it worth now um no one
knows
because there's none for sale if you
wear watch like that out
do people recognize you know the watch
this one i had no idea
i would look at this watch and think oh
it could be a few grand
no one would have no idea never um
a watch geek mic like i've been stopped
at starbucks
by like a fellow wash geek and been like
that's a nice rolex but it's the rolex
it's not the moser
what makes this 35 grand because i'm
trying to look like the stainless steel
no so yeah first the movement okay
which if you look at the back is all
hand engraved hand finished
fully in-house they actually use gold
countersinks in the movement it's just
the level of detail is fantastic okay
then the second thing is the dial is
made entirely out of aventurine which is
a sparkling gemstone
um which also is how how much does that
sell for
intrinsically probably a few hundred
dollars to be honest
honest with you but it's not the
intrinsic value of the stone
it's more the fact that if you want to
watch with an aventurine dial
there aren't really any i mean there's a
couple out there
but it's it's so if if i have to tell
you where the money
is on this piece it's the labor the
hours of swiss trained labor that went
into building it yeah
that's where all the money i'll give you
now cash
right now seven grand absolutely not
what are you doing in my job
let's see i will i counter offer at 70.
70. seven me in the middle i counter
offer a ten what if i give you more
moves
uh all right so moving on to um
so this is actually a gift for grammar
no
what is this nothing that special it's
actually a swatch
uh which is rare it's a limited run
swatch really
there are a few swatches worth a few
thousand dollars this is not one of them
okay
but it is a limited run switch and i saw
it
and it's got the coffee cup on it i love
this is this something that
i should not be wearing because if it's
it's old
well it's from the 90s but i liked it
because it came with the full kit you've
got the original price tag
in the box oh i shouldn't wear this then
i would keep this as is okay
it was like a collection i was trying to
think like if i put this on the second
channel like wear it but
it's so perfectly preserved
i don't want it in japan actually wow
dang what was the original price on this
oh probably like 50 bucks wow but i just
saw it you know the 20 cent coffee thing
you know
i'm a fan of your channel and had the
coffee cup i thought
like it was pretty funny i love this
thank you no it's my pleasure i love
this can i see it and that's
the show guys you don't have to be a
millionaire i know we're talking like
crazy numbers right now
you don't have to be a millionaire to
love watches
there are some great watches for a few
hundred bucks
even less i mean in the big boy leagues
yes
they're thousands of dollars but anybody
can what would you recommend for people
with under a thousand dollars right now
to spend who want to get into the watch
game but our audience is really
price sensitive sure and wants something
that is going to hold its value
will go up so under the house watches in
that price point
don't hold value very well however buy
pre-owned
which will retain better value and i say
like a collectible seiko
like a seiko if you can put up a picture
like a seiko tuna or a seiko turtle
iconic watches for 500 bucks
um you should be able to sell it for
pretty darn close to what you paid for
it
if you want to go swiss you don't have
many choices but
like a hamilton you know pre-owned
hamilton if you buy your new hamilton
you just lost 70 percent but a pre-owned
hamilton
is a nice swiss watch that should hold
value
decently okay rolex explorer should we
talk about it
uh yeah pick it up all right i like you
know what i think those watches
um are undervalued i think uh they're
underappreciated
and i think they're a solid watch for
what six grand i'm guessing
yeah i'm not gonna say undervalued
anymore because this watch
two years ago it's a rolex first
generation 36 millimeter explorer
i was selling for like four thousand
dollars um but now with the full kit the
box and papers
this one just sold this morning so it's
not available
uh for sixty eight hundred dollars yeah
sixty eight hundred
sixty eight hundred and it's gone up as
you saw twenty eight hundred dollars
in about two years that's really good
that's a good roi to go from four to six
yeah
once again this is the crazy market
we're in right now
i don't recommend any of your viewers
do it just to do just to make an roi i
think
an index fund as you say yeah is a much
safer investment but it's a great hobby
yeah where you can have a ton of
expensive fun
and not lose i think that's like
the key yeah in my opinion it's a game
you can't lose like a blackjack
blackjack yeah we had blackjack gambling
last night we all so did
we did you win absolutely not oh
oh we i we did so well so i i put in
200. walked away with like
550 but i only played 100. i
i kept 100 aside the entire time so i
turned 100 into like 300 something in
profit
no comment we got lucky i was down
i was down about 70 bucks and then just
hand over hand
yeah doubling win double win
it's just every hand like 780 money
making machine and then as soon as
the deck ended and they still
reshuffling we're like no this is it
i should just say this i hope this video
sells me some watches because last night
was pain
how much you lose yeah not not you know
enough
how much like over over a grand just
about
that's okay we're used to people losing
like tens of thousands of dollars
like 30 grand today i'll play a little
bit more i got i got profit
today i got yeah i'm going to turn my
profit oh my gosh this is turning into a
habit that's fun
it's a social
that's that's always how much i'll go in
with and lose
uh in like a whole weekend that's it 300
bucks
most i would say it's a 50 50. i'd say
it's just like this
i don't lose in the long run because if
you play correctly
i'll win 100 i'll lose a hundred i'll
win a hundred i'll lose so long term i'm
probably break even but i have so much
fun and it's a good
like stuff i i have a great time
it's entertainment and i don't i'm not
making stupid bets
but i'm probably even overall i'll put
it this way after losing last night
which was a little
painful yeah me and my brother went to
carbone and easily
doubled our loss on a fantastic dinner
yeah and
it was just i woke up and it didn't even
matter anymore it doesn't i mean it
matters a lot of money but like i'm over
it yeah
there we go all right let's see what's
in here
is that alligator uh that is a cost
custom-made ostrich
ostrich ah that's ostrich alright jack
come up describe it and uh
say how much you think it's worth and
then i'll give my guess yeah what do you
think is the retail price of that one
okay so the name of this y try to
pronounce it what is i don't know what
it is
is a tourbillon 30 seconds
that is the function not the name of the
[Music]
it doesn't have any labeling on it uh
it's got a b on it
oh you're right it doesn't have a
breitling
no that's not i love it oh no you're
right it has no name it has the name on
the back oh okay let me uh
it should have the name on the back at
least this is called a 30 0
30 30 joules adjusted five positions
[Music]
yes that's that's that's a great market
it is called uh
3 40 p.m it is a parmigiani
fleurier pershing tourbillon
they only made 12 of these in the entire
world
um this one is brand new
not pre-owned brand new and how much how
much would you say the retail prices on
that
okay so it feels to me light so it's
titanium
and rose gold okay but what makes it
special
is the tourbillon movement all right so
i'm looking at serbia so i know
tourbillon's
minimum 50 grand yeah so
minimum very cool feature
uh
it's over i'd say over it's got to be
only 12. i
would say probably 120 but jack you get
you give a guess on that
okay basing off of the uh the weight
the uh structural integrity integrity
of the watch um the complications yeah
the
back looks pretty good to me i'm gonna
have to say 1
25. so this bad boy carries an
original dinosaur have jack hold it as
you're saying that let's see
an original msrp of 243 thousand dollars
um would you care to guess how much
this watch is for sale at
delraywatch.com brand new box and papers
would you care to guess how much i'm
selling it for
brand new you guys one of twelve 255
two no no 300 300 if that's an off roll
take it
to what is it 220
i'm i'm gonna my guess is uh
it's minimum 50. so i'm going to say
probably 70
65. so i'm selling it for exactly 50
000. ah which i think it's basically the
yeah listen you can think of this two
ways
if you were the crazy guy who bought
this at the parmigiani boutique in miami
and paid full price you just lost
80 of your money wow or
if you're the crazy guy that loves this
watch because it's unique it's beautiful
they only made 12
and you want to buy it now brand new for
me for 50 you just saved 80
but why why did this lose so much value
and why is it just not
nobody wanting it it's not a bad watch
the watch is fantastic
it is all handmade it's super exclusive
it's just a very small brand uh i'll
give you an idea i know you're a car guy
okay spiker i love spiker
i love spiker too they've been going up
in value a lot though now they have but
why in the in when they were first out
why didn't no one buy them you know why
did no one buy
uh tvr you know that british car company
they're not bad cars there's just nobody
knew what it was but that was never
really imported to the us
you have a few examples but that was
never so i think the tvr that we could
maybe exclude that spiker i just think
they never
made it well i guess that's the same
with this they never made enough of them
they never made enough of them nobody
knows who they are
they make two three thousand watchers a
year they've got a crazy amount of
collectors
now the real question is hey federico
how did you get it
for so cheap the truth is it's a small
company
they've got a very small amount of
employees and occasionally brands
will call dealers and be like we need to
sell this
you know because every brand's got to
pay bills and i made them an offer
and they sold it to me how many people
paid full price for that though
and this 12 sold my guess is six
what is a tourbillon
orological questions um we're gonna need
a whole bunch of diagrams that explain
this one but i'll do my very best
tourbillon is a function of a watch
which
should counteract the gravity you know
the earth's gravitational pull
so the watch works off a spring that
rotates
the tourbillon puts that spring in a
cage and
rotates it once per minute or in this
case twice per minute
so gravity which is always pulling
downwards will affect that spring
equally because the spring is
turning wow so essentially it's a very
it's a very high-end piece of
engineering
which is done through micro mechanics
which really brings up
the price of a watch yeah i've seen the
ap
turbines and they're all like 80 grand
70 grand
and cheap tourbillons yeah so more than
that now much more
really they've gone up late i mean i
guess the last time i checked prices
were probably about a year ago
some of them are but if you want like
the one everybody wants like the concept
term or
you know quarter million dollars no
problem wow i mean you can get them
you can just i'm looking at like i i go
ebay sort by least
at least to high and like i'm like all
right that's how it is got to be careful
with ebay though
by the seller that's okay that's what i
said but how do you charge one of these
to go so this one plug it in
it's got the ac got the usb port
so this one is manually wound so you
turn the crown
and it's got a power zero feature here
uh which is eight days
so on a full wind you'll have an eight
day charge
on the watch so every eight days you
wind a lot of people argue
that it's just a rich person's toy um
because
who really needs to counteract the
effects of gravity in 2021
and it's pretty cool to be doing that
and you're rich do you know what i mean
you're that rich you're like
i don't got time nobody got time for
grabbing exactly
literally you got time for it okay and
we got i think
one last goodie here and then you look
at my collection oh absolutely yeah
i want to show you what i got jack is
that a submariner yeah
no here's your watch what what's the
dial black dial yeah absolutely
you got the green dial wow rolex
submarine
green green bezel sorry dial and bezel
oh
wow can i see how this looks on my
disease so this is the watch i bought
myself for my 29th birthday
wow um as i've said previously i find
rolex to be a little
boring you know a little common but i
saw the green on green and i said well
that's the most iconic watch in the
world the submariner
with a little bit of that cash money pop
yeah so
i decided obviously my wrist is way
larger than yours but
you know what it it's it's weird with
the stainless steel on the gold ring
yeah that might throw i might throw it
now he needs a gold submariner
i think without the ring or you put the
ring on the other hand did you put
what's the significance of the ring on
that hand but why does it need to be on
that finger on that hand
i just like it a lot you can't put it on
the other hand i i my dad's wedding ring
i uh
i casted the exact same ring okay out of
the same gold but you can't put it on
the other hand
it's pretty stuck i mean i could
probably figure out a way to like get it
off
but it's pretty stuck you can laser it
off you know does that look right to you
look at how uh my knuckle is like
weighted
right now no you don't you can't you
just make that bigger
and put it on the other hand like it's
cutting off your hands growing around
that doesn't look healthy yeah yeah i i
honestly
you might want to expand the size of the
ring a little bit and put it on the
other hand
put it this way if you fly like get on
an airplane with that ring
your finger might just explode
all right i'll definitely look into this
a little bit i'm not like i'm not even
like as a friendly guy yeah so
okay all right it's not like i never i
never paid attention to but now that
now that you're showing that all i know
well i didn't want to bring attention to
it
but everybody look at his hand but it's
one of those things that like you never
notice it until you point it out and
it's all you can my knuckle is larger
than the ring like significant that's
your body screaming for help yes
honestly
we're both telling you this i've never
looked at this until then i'm not
kidding with you
i would highly recommend resizing that
right getting it taken
off yeah expanding it a little bit and
i don't care if you put it back on the
same finger but
make that ring a little bigger hey
graeme i say it for you buddy how's this
guy gonna end a video missing a finger
yeah that's true yeah listen i like i
like the watching you i think i think
that's the watch is so great submariner
i think that's an awful example because
i've got an eight inch wrist and yeah
he's got a skinny
right but yeah it's listen it's a great
looking watch i went for the green
just because you know and actually i
bought it for eight thousand dollars
wow that's what we're 13 now 17.
17. because it was just discontinued
beautiful watch the one watch that i
really wanted that i didn't get that i'm
regretting
uh when they came out with the uh the
daytona with the green dial
oh yeah and john mayer yes killed it and
and what had with that when that came
out it reminded me
for some reason of a craps table at las
vegas with the green felt and the green
dial
and i thought gosh that would be an
awesome watch to get and i just thought
you know what it's too
flashy it's too bright baby yes
but i loved the color combination of
that watch
and that was back when it was selling
about 30
to 33 and there are a whole bunch of
them for sale
it's like double that now yep
and uh and i've realized now anytime
i've liked something to that point where
i'm like oh that's a gorgeous one like i
want
that but i'm not gonna get it it always
goes up every single time
what think of it this way i mean i know
i know your whole thing is you're
extremely
financially responsible yeah and you
should keep that up because you're doing
your viewers a great service
but in this case wasn't it extremely
financially irresponsible not to buy
that rolex yeah
wow oh same here's here's another
example of just when i didn't listen to
myself over this
um when i was like 22 23
i really wanted the zenith rolex daytona
stainless steel black dial and those
were selling
for less money than the normal rolex
daytonas i didn't get it
why does nobody want the zenith it was
only made for like this is a rare watch
why does nobody want it i thought
maybe it's just it's old and people just
don't want that and i wanted that watch
and those were selling about 9 900 bucks
maybe about 10 11 000.
um and i didn't get it because i thought
well it's a lot of money to spend on
ten thousand dollars and now it's like
35 40 grand for that same watch
yeah yeah you see yeah this is guys
this all this means is you got to hit me
up
you know call me for your watchers and
but now i'm trying to think like what i
would buy
now um and i'm not really sure
like i'm looking at these watches i
don't see anything to me right now that
really stands out is like i gotta get
that watch i'll tell you this yeah i've
been i've been watching
you for a little while and i've always
realized you had
nice watches yeah you never really point
them out in your video but
right now you're wearing a classic retro
inspired zenithel primero
now it's actually this is the retro one
actually here let me show you my watch
this is your grandpa's watch
you told me correctly this is it yeah so
this is the original 1969 zenith el
primero it was never worn
before me and it was just kept in a box
yeah this is one of
the nicest examples by far thanks
that i have ever seen yeah when i took
it in so i took it into
i found a vintage rolex forum online
when i found this watch i post it up
there
everyone is telling me dude take it
immediately there's a there's a
a person who services rolex watches
downtown la
i took it to this guy he was florida
with the original box
no papers but had the original box
original strap
this guy said this watch was fought he
had never seen an example like this
before
this is one of the nicest ones i've ever
seen yeah honestly it's beautiful
and i also know you have a panerai yes i
do i didn't bring it
okay but yeah i love that padaway thank
you yeah that was uh
i've had that watch for a while and uh
but yeah this is uh
this is watch number one and this is one
of those things honestly i've i beat
this watch unfortunately
and i've scraped you could see on the
right light i've scraped the uh
the front the crystal on this and uh you
know what that polished out
yeah but this is one of those things
where i don't want to keep this watch
pristine it's like this is one of those
ones where i feel like i just gotta wear
it and i love it and the only thing i'll
tell you is just keep that away from
water
oh yeah like keep it away from like the
pool the shower
oh i do yeah yeah any moisture like i'm
not gonna take it to the beach or
anything like that but
uh but i wear this around this is by far
the watch i wear the most often should
be
that's how it should be i mean there's
nothing worse to me honestly it's a
little bit of a rant
somebody who spends can they grab me the
box a ton of money on a watch
that doesn't wear it what's the point
that's why jack when you get your sub
please wear it that's that's um
i will say yeah i don't i i this is hold
on
okay so this is the other rolex
okay this is a 36 millimeter datejust
current generation fluted blue dial
i'm gonna be honest this is um this is
just a fantastic watch for every day
there's no occasion where this does not
work you can wear this to the sauna to
the beach
or you can wear it on a suit it's
extremely classic
white gold dial oh sorry bezel michael
deville is the best part
okay this is the best part of the watch
yep
guys it's engraved i don't know if they
can see this you put b-roll it's
engraved with two
million subscribers um
which apart from your grandfather's
watch yeah which is always going to be
number one
this has to be the most special watch in
your collection just for this was a gift
it was a gift grant navarre i think you
might meet him later he'll
probably come out with us if you want to
meet him he brought his watch collection
by the way
he's got a gnarly watch he's got an
insane watch collection
so um you'll meet him he got me that as
a gift when i hit 2 million subscribers
he sent me this that is an incredible
gesture yeah and this is why when you
get your sub
you want a milestone because you're
going to have this forever oh yeah
and it's going to mean something forever
and he got you a watch which is honestly
wearable on the occasion mr navarre has
fantastic taste
yep yep so this i love the blue dial oh
he also got me a mont blanc pen
that matches get out of here really yeah
this guy's detail-oriented yes
oh extremely but yeah this is one of
those pieces that like you passed down
like this these are
like like we were talking tattoos the
other week and i was like i don't have
any
tattoos but for me like these like like
big
events or stuff like that that happens
to me it's like you get a watch
or you get something like this that you
could pass down and once again it's not
fiscally irresponsible because if done
right
you're not technically out of the money
you're just parking at something right
then we got this you know what's i love
that watch but i'm also extremely
intrigued by that box so this is a solid
rose gold remake of the 1969 el primero
it's got the same case profile uh it's
got the sapphire case back so you can
see the alcamera movement
which is something that was never done
back when your grandpa's watch was
manufactured i
like it better in steel but i love this
to death
because you're obviously paying homage
to your grandpa yes by getting a new
50th anniversary the new version so you
have the old and the new you must be one
of the few
people on earth one of the very few
people on earth
that owns the old iteration
and the new iteration yeah of the watch
now
this is one i mean i would wear this
for very special occasions i wear this
all the time
like gold is a little tougher for me to
pull off all the time and
it looks good on you i've seen it in
your videos but i don't know what makes
it super cool to me is you have
both yes that's what's so special right
i thought about getting the white gold
because they only did uh precious metals
so they did yellow gold
rose and white um i thought the white
would have been too similar to that and
would have looked like the same thing
agreed i thought yellow gold oh wait no
this is yellow gold sorry this is yellow
yeah
i didn't i thought the rose might have
been a little too trendy so i figured
the yellow gold
would be more of like a classic color
i mean this is a very handsome watch
look at that it
shines a lot that's what i have to say
but
it's still like a zenith i mean this is
a watch geek
watch yeah if somebody stops you in the
street and like
hey man what's that watch and you say
zenith they'll think you have a you know
the tv company
yeah that's it the radio yeah um but but
no i mean people that know
zenith makes one of the best and
probably the most iconic
chronograph movement um stopwatch
movement for
the layman uh in in in the watch world
so this is something i just bought the
guy was going through some financial
difficulty those are usually the best
deals
sold it to me at like half price cash
so i'll let you do the honors all right
let me see
put that right there for now so
get out of here so i picked this up for
like 20 something thousand cash
you stole it yeah guys this is
am i taking this box yeah sure yeah so
this is
a rolex day-date nicknamed the president
with the green dial uh also made
extremely famous
by john mayer um usually
solid gold rolex doesn't hold value
extremely well
generally this is a major exception to
that rule
this style is sold out everywhere
um it's a little flashy but it's
supposed to be
yeah that's the whole purpose of this
watch
and it's just it's i mean this
am i holding this for a second
this is not real why did you break so
easily graham
you bro easily oh
i couldn't i couldn't hold back okay but
i will tell you how long did it take me
to spot how long
i mean i was okay in my mind i was
telling jack i was preparing for this
oh yeah i made the dial pretty uh pretty
small in my mind i was going to pretend
to be like
not knowing it was fake and you were
supposed to tell me like oh
this isn't that out so much i planned
this out i couldn't i couldn't
i was breaking her yeah yeah i like put
my head down because i didn't even
notice it yeah
yeah as soon as you as soon as you took
it out and
i said but okay the plan was that uh
that i was going to pretend it was real
and you could be like no it's not
real and i guess it is
okay i'm just proud that i don't look
awful on camera being a professional
dealer and i'm just proud that like i
caught it yeah that's all i wanted
because i was worried you were holding
it talking about it and like it's a
light watch you're not going to know
until you take it
off because it looks good listen if
you're this far away i'm not going to
lie
it looks okay yeah but you take it off
and it feels like
crap like it really does um
i am so disappointed in myself i was
going to play it out and like have like
i can't believe are you serious like no
no well enough
that you would have never bought
something like this for yourself
okay so fun i did want this watch and i
thought to myself
uh before i spend the money on the real
thing
i'm gonna get a replica version wear it
for a little bit
see if i like it and then if it wears
off i'm not gonna buy the real thing
sure enough i got this wore it maybe a
few times just to see what it's like and
uh lost uh lost the appeal but i love
the watch
fair enough i mean listen it's a
beautiful watch it's just not very grim
yeah in my in my opinion i love the
green dial
the olive green you're gonna punk me
yeah on your channel
right now is that was that is that the
plan yeah invite me all the way to vegas
and
make me schlep all the way out here and
you're gonna punch we were so excited
for that
you were quick you were quick to spawn
that would have been even worse
i love this watch wow you got such a
deal here you go but then i would have
thought too you were just being polite
like you didn't want to tell me it was
fake
like on camera play a long time honestly
when you told me how much you paid for
it before i held it i was prepared to
make you an offer i'd be like i'll pay
you 30.
i will not pay you it would have been
worse it would have been worse had you
not
caught it that quickly yeah can you
guess how much it was
70 bucks no no no okay real realistic
realistically how much do you think that
replica is worth i mean it's worth
nothing how much would you pay for it
yes so you got a swiss etta replica it
feels like like it's got a swiss
movement
i mean on the replica forums must be
like 280 300 bucks something like that
yeah i think it was about 350 okay with
shipping and everything
here's the thing yeah the the head looks
great
it's just a bracelet yeah which feels
awful it's the
uh yeah that being said i don't condone
um
you know i'm just i don't condone it but
yeah
listen it could be worse i appreciate
the fact that you just said like this is
fake
like immediately like you didn't even
consider like a shoot should i not say
this yeah
but like yeah i would be very careful
i would just look at it and you know
good luck
this is nice this is nice hand it back
immediately like the last
i no time handling again i do this for a
living you know when people call me
every day
and send me pictures and walk into my
office
and like yeah you're right i probably
should have been more polite but like
it's a reflex for christ
but i started laughing too quickly which
that's my fault
yeah yeah you should take this to the m
and see if anybody will give you like a
marker against it
so i i think let's uh how long are we in
the punk right
90 minutes so we're good but i do have a
couple questions please please please
so what was the first watch that you got
the first
watch i got or the first um like
high-end watch i got the first
watch you got yeah first watch i got was
called a swatch
b okay it was a digital watch
where swatch actually invented this new
thing called internet time
so that it it's a new way of telling
time where the time would be the same
all around the world
obviously it didn't take off this was in
the late 90s i got it when i was like
10 years old on vacation um
very very cool like digital watch i
actually had a cartoon
for some reason if you held on the
button for too long had a cartoon of a
dog
peeing on a lamp i'm not sure where that
even i
don't even know why that was a thing but
yeah it was the swatch swatch
beat beat e80 bea cool
um so what was your first luxury watch
my first like
luxury watch that i spent my own money
for uh was an
iwc engineer blue dial
a watch i actually just recently sold
for my collection
why would you sell something that has so
much sentimental value i
because it had sentimental value and and
i
here's the thing i agree with
sentimental value as i just give you the
whole spiel about sentimental value
but at the same time i make a youtube
show about watches i sell watches i
touch watchers every day i want to
experience
as many watches as possible and i don't
have the financial ability to just keep
buying and buying and buying and buying
and not selling
i have the memories the memories will be
with me forever
you know i've made videos about it those
will live forever or as least as
as long as youtube survives so you know
i'm always connected with that watch but
unfortunately
these are expensive items and sometimes
i just have to make
you know the executive decision
and you know make way for other things
and how much did you buy it for and how
much do you sell it for
so it was nine thousand dollars i got an
employee discount for five thousand
because i was working in the watch
industry and i sold it for
4 800. that's a pretty good deal to have
a watch for so long
i lost 200 bucks and um
how many watches do you currently own uh
this is gonna sound so pompous
i actually don't know um i mean
i'm sure i could figure it out if i wait
if i do the mental math
but i don't actually have i actually
don't know somewhere between like eight
and twelve
okay do you ever wear non-expensive
watches
occasionally i mean yes because there's
some that i just
genuinely like like i love my seiko
i have a swatch that i love but at the
same time when i have the ability to
wear all these beautiful things
you might as well that i've worked so
hard of then i mean
i consider myself relatively humble i
mean i know what matters in my life
so you know why do i have to pretend
you know a lot of people say well how
could you wear that around how could you
put tenth out because
because i enjoy it and because i can and
because
you know it's um you know it makes me
feel special what can i say
how do you think the popularity of
watches will hold up in the next
30 50 100 years
i think watches are no longer tools
unfortunately people don't
need them it all depends how much people
want them
the watch market seems to be growing
thankfully
particularly the vintage watch market i
think millennials
are starting to think watchers are cool
not for their utility
but because they're considered retro
like even a new rolex is like
retro tech and just like retro gaming is
making a huge comeback i can kind of see
watches
falling into that kind of cool factor uh
as well
you know that's what i think at least
where would you recommend buying a watch
now i know you're obviously
you know you're but what do you think
about buying launches on ebay and chrono
24
i think uh that can be a great and an
awful idea at the same time
you gotta remember ebay is not selling
you the watch chrono 24 is not selling
you the watch
some guy who posted on ebay and posted
on chrono 24 is selling you the watch
you don't know that guy um if you have
no idea about watches and it's your
first watch
buy from a trusted source you know buy
from a retail store pay full price on
your first watch or buy pre-owned
maybe for me or somebody else that you
trust trust the number one
if you're like me and or like you and
and you know watches
really well then sure go on ebay go on
chrono24
get a good deal but you remember it
comes with inherent risks there's fraud
there's payment processing issues
if you're ready to potentially deal with
that which i
am you know i am because i know what i'm
doing then go for it
but i don't recommend anybody's
anybody's first
or second watch brochures be on a
marketplace
what if it comes with box and papers how
much does does that not matter can you
swap them internals
and it matters because papers are worth
make a watch worth more
but just like the chinese can fake a
watch or chinese can fake papers
or or you know wherever the fakes are
made i mean
papers are worthless unless you can
verify like to me papers are worth
everything because i know what a fake
pair of rolex papers looks like but if
papers should not make you feel
safe so now since i like i work in
youtube and stuff like that whenever i'm
browsing youtube and i see youtube
videos
like i'm constantly analyzing the
thumbnail and the title it's just
something that like
in the back of my mind i'm fixated on
when you enter
a room full of like people or if you're
at a party or something like that if
you're at the casino
are you constantly looking around for
just buying watches
first thing i see it's just subconscious
it's no
work it's just i look at people's wrists
and you identify everything's like okay
got it
usually yes can you spawn fakes how
often do you spot fakes when you're at
the casino um
often than you'd think okay i mean let's
say this this
let's say my watch yeah if i were this
far away from you
i'd say would you be able to eat i'd say
from a distant snow but as soon as i
touched it
okay from a distant snow okay but it's a
relatively good fake
you know there are others that um
you know there's there's some pretty bad
ones usually it doesn't have to be off
the wrist
for me to spot it how often do people
try to come to you with a fake trying to
sell it to you or trying to pass it off
as real
i mean it happens a couple times a month
and it's always with some story that
you know oh my grandfather left this to
me and i don't know what it's worth
or my friend it's always a story like i
got it from
this guy and i want to sell it i'm like
okay like
and i you know i don't tell them it's
fake because it's not trying to get into
an altercation you know with them
because people get upset
yeah so i always say you know just take
it to rolex have authenticated and come
back with the papers
that's like my way of saying yeah yeah
got it come back yeah
what is your all-time favorite watch and
your all-time least favorite watch
i don't have an all-time favorite watch
because it changes the daily i'm sure
that yeah you wouldn't whatever sell
stuff
answer yeah almost overrated or just
like least favorite watch
most overrated this is going to sound
awful oh i know what you're going to say
is rolex i think rolex makes a fantastic
watch
they make a great watch great watch
but it really is like the level of like
cultism that follows that brand
i'll tell you i don't understand but
it's not i'm not saying it's a bad watch
i just think it's just so
crazily hyped um but i think the brand i
like the least like one i wouldn't
like wearing i know cause you talk about
it all the time um
i mean there's always a brand from watch
i'd wear i don't love most tag warriors
um even though i there are a few that i
would what what what is the brand i talk
about all the time
oh yeah i used to own a who yeah i used
to own a hublot
but you know yeah hublot
it's not for me to me that is i would
say my least
i don't even remember them as a watch
brand to me i would say that's my least
favorite brand of watches is generally
hooplo
uh one though i think one of the biggest
reasons i don't like them
is because every watch they have is
limited edition but when
everything is a limited edition nothing
is uh the other thing with hublot is i
feel like they
have replicated ap a little bit too much
in their design and
aesthetic and um but for half the price
and
the resale is terrible and i'd say just
for resale alone
is terrible they'll last 20k and then
you find the same watch for like
eight same thing a brand i'm starting to
dislike
great watchers but i'm starting to
really dislike his ap
because everything is the same it's all
the same it's like a hundred years
of the same the same royal oak royal oak
royal oak road
offshore royal look safari royal oak
ultra thin it's like
guys like beating the dead horse
and i have nothing bad to say about them
apart from the lack of originality
because they hold value well they're
beautiful watches are extremely well
made
but like let's change it up and then
they made the quote 1159 which was their
new release
and everybody just hated it what do you
think last last one
tech love them um
love them i think they run the risk of
being a little complacent
with their production i think there are
finer watches in the world than patek
they are not the best
watch in the world but you know just
genius marketing
fantastic products history second to
none
they make sports watchers make dress
watches so they make something for
everybody
i mean i will own a patek in my life
i will own one um the one i really want
here's here's one that's about to go up
in valley because i've wanted this watch
for a while the calatrava
the old the the best value yep sure
sub 20k yeah which doesn't make any
sense to me because it's a patek it's so
simple it's so elegant
it's beautifully designed and i think
it's one of the most classic watches out
there that's patek
under 20. unbelievable what did i tell
you let me give you a piece of
let me give you mr mr graham stefan a
piece of advice here
financial advice buy one they're at the
lowest they've ever been why
and they're at the lowest ever will be
why because it's not trendy right now
but they've been
okay so true but they've been at that
price from when i started looking at the
tech
i've had my eye on one of those and and
unlike any other like the rolex daytonas
and the zeniths and
everything else has gone up except for
that watch but it's not going to be like
that forever
but it will go up it is a great watch it
is special
will it go up will it take a little bit
of time sure but i don't see them could
you
i can't see it going any lower could you
find me one because because otherwise
i'd go on ebay
and listen yeah i can't if i if i can't
find you one at the very least
i can tell you which one to buy that i
don't have
really i mean i'll do that for fun i
don't know it's like a friend thing
uh i would look i would buy a cali
drawer
i would do that i think it's a fantastic
watch i think it's like i wish i could
own anything like it no i wish i had a
milestone to like uh
three million three million subscribers
hundred hundred thousand million
subscribers you get like a new watch for
your collection
or a hundred thousand subscribers on the
phone on the podcast yeah oh
you're selling yourself making up your
celebration is me getting my submarine
all right and
now everything is a miles about a
milestone federico coming to vegas
yeah yeah all right um i'll do that
i would get that watch i mean i'm just
it's just there's no there's no
you're never going to get a cheaper in
my opinion obviously i don't have a
crystal ball but
i don't think you'll ever get it cheaper
than what it is right now
okay if if you if you could bring me a
watch under 20k
on a good deal on it on a travel under
20k i mean just like
like a good a good deal with with boxes
like a collectible watch that you feel
preferably box and papers that is
good condition that i could just wear
we're gonna do we're gonna hang out
after those yeah you know
we're going to talk and you're going to
show me what style what color travels
you like
and then we'll figure it out we'll take
it from there i'll do it okay
it's perfect cool and i'll you know what
if i if you buy for me
if it happens that way yeah i'll handle
over to you you know what i'll hand
deliver it to vegas okay deal all right
perfect all right i'll do it i i i've
been to this watch for 10 years i've
never bought it and
you're right the price has not gone up
on this watch um
it will eventually i mean worst case
scenario
it's going to fall i mean it's been at
this yeah i mean it
these watches are like 30 years old 20
years old and they've just
the same maybe plus or minus like two
percent but
okay deal all right perfect well guys
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it this was probably one of
the most
insightful because i'm so curious about
it and uh
it's this is something i've just been
genuinely interested in but i've yet to
talk to anybody at length about watches
before
so guys thank you so much for watching
i'm going to link to your information
down below in the description thank you
for having me it's not sponsored or
anything like that but you if you if you
want anything watch related
uh this is your goal don't even put the
shops link just put my youtube channel
there you go just the youtube channel
you can find the shop link on
my channel before you talk about it
non-stop if you really want to
you have the option all right there we
go also make sure to add us on
instagram uh make sure to get your four
free stocks have you done that have you
gotten your four free stocks on weeble
uh we're actually gonna do that right
after this deal okay so you'll get your
four free stocks and weeble
uh you'll have you signed up for yada
savings no i haven't okay yeah also sign
up for yana savings and uh with ted said
you guys thank you so much for watching
oh you got to subscribe if we're not yet
at 100k
if you made it to this point you haven't
subscribed yet just do it it's easy it's
free
and uh we'll be at 100k any any moment
now so i could get that calatrava
and with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching until next time take
care
cool what's up you guys it's federico
uh welcome back to the 36th sixth
ever so you need to ever ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
and so far we have made and then just
say that number
but really quickly guys we have a word
from our sponsor audible audible is the
leading provider of spoken word
entertainment audiobooks and they
recently added podcasts i'm someone who
values constantly learning new things
and audible is an amazing platform that
offers over 500
000 audio titles audible offers spoken
word entertainment ranging from
celebrity memoirs and motivational
speeches to original content from
celebrity creators and thousands of
binge-worthy podcasts
i'm way too busy right now to divert all
of my attention to a book and read so
instead i just put on audible when i'm
doing my daily runs or in my car driving
i am currently listening to misbehaving
which is a book by richard thaler on
behavioral economics and its effect on
us
i know i definitely would not have
enough time to read this book if it
weren't for audible and guess what guys
you're in luck because right now you can
get in on the president's day event
you are getting in on one of the best
offers of the year it's only 9.95 a
month for your first six months
when i signed up for audible about eight
months ago i was paying way more than
this
so if you want to check that out visit
audible.com iced coffee or text iced
coffee to 500
500. it's as easy as that just text iced
coffee to 500
500. also if you want more information
as always check the description and with
that said
back to the podcast